so today for our cancellation i want to
briefly revisit the conversation we had
yesterday to start the show about
prostitution and pornography especially
the kind
you find on sites like only fans um many
prominent voices on the left including
aoc and
the aclu and many others have recently
been promoting prostitution in
particular
cyber prostitution as real work sex work
is real work they say
now i made the case that if a woman
getting paid to take off her clothes on
camera is doing
real work which i don't think she is but
if she is it's certainly a very
different kind of work
from the type performed by members of
legitimate and noble professions
the prostitute is selling her dignity
for profit she is debasing herself for
the enjoyment of strangers it is a
shameful dirty
bad way to make a living and it should
not be normalized or mainstreamed or
promoted
now the first thing to realize about my
point on this subject is that it is
completely
obvious and nearly everyone in the world
would have agreed with it up until 12
seconds ago
i have and this happens to me a lot i've
received a hell of a lot of backlash for
saying something that
10 billion people throughout history
have already said
and that nearly everyone would have
taken for granted as a simple
and incontrovertible fact it has never
been easier to be controversial to be a
provocateur
all you have to do is say stuff like
it's not good to be a prostitute or
men don't menstruate and suddenly you
become edgy
you're edgy now for saying that when in
reality you're saying the least
edgy things a person could possibly say
but the left has been so successful in
their war on reality and on common sense
and on basic human decency and morality
that even people who are not on the left
now suddenly
are treating these common sense
propositions as controversial
if not outright unspeakable
um with all that said i have one other
point i wanted to make in relation
to this topic and i i hesitate to make
it only because i fear that i might be
giving my critics too much
credit with this argument that i will
present um i'm not sure if i i hope i'm
not
giving them too much credit but the
point is this
if you're a parent and you're also among
the people who have gotten angry at me
for saying that prostitution and
pornography are shameful and debasing
industries
and that neither women nor men should be
involved in it
and then it's bad for for for it's it's
bad for everybody involved
if you disagree and again if you're a
parent yourself
then why don't you want your own
daughter to be a prostitute
or a porn star now
like i said i may be giving you too much
credit it's possible that you're even
more depraved than i anticipate
but my guess is that for all of your
talk about the validity and nobility
and empowerment of prostitution you have
not
ever and would not ever encourage your
daughter to grow up and become one
you have not and would not look at a
little seven-year-old girl in your home
who you love and wish to protect and
think to yourself
i really hope she sets up an only fan's
account when she's old enough
i'm guessing and certainly hoping that
you have never ever
ever had that thought and never would
have it
but why i mean you say it's empowering
and liberating for women to do this you
say it's noble it's good
why don't you want your daughter to do
this empowering liberating thing
don't you want her to be liberated you
know it's also empowering and liberating
to be a mother
a doctor a scientist a business owner an
artist and you probably would be quite
happy for your daughter to become any
one of those things wouldn't you
in fact you may even actively want them
to become one of those things or
something similar
and if you notice as your child grows
older that she has a proclivity for
science or medicine or art
you would start guiding her in a certain
direction so that she can one day have a
career in those fields
yet as your child grows older and she
spends time on social media
if she starts acting inappropriately
there you would never in a million years
upon finding out about that say to your
daughter you know you might have a great
future as a prostitute
why why wouldn't you say that
you're saying this is a good thing yet
you wouldn't want your child to do it
that's strange isn't it so again i ask
why
well i know why of course you don't want
your daughter in this life because it's
a shameful degrading life
and women who do it are prone to become
drug addicts and to kill themselves
in fact a great many prostitutes as
studies have repeatedly shown have a
history of being sexually abused too
that's what's that is what propels
people to get into this line of work
a history of abuse and neglect you know
that porn and prostitution
are things that damaged people do and if
your child ends up doing it it means
that
they are damaged you don't want your
child to be damaged
you don't want her to to make a living
as masturbation fodder for creeps on the
internet
or glorified sex toys for guys they meet
in motel rooms
you don't want that for her i hope you
don't want it because you love your
child
i would suggest this if there is
something
that you wouldn't ever want anyone you
love
to ever do then you shouldn't want
anyone to do it
now there are other things a parent
might be apprehensive about their son
joining the military for fear of his
safety but
they would still be proud that he joined
right
their heart would swell with pride when
he when he when he went off to basic
training
would your heart swell with pride the
first time your daughter goes to have
sex with a customer in his car
would your eyes well up with tears of
happiness upon hearing that your
daughter earned her first subscriber on
only fans
no it wouldn't because you don't want
that for her
you don't because in your heart you know
that i'm right
about everything i'm saying and you're
wrong
and that's why you don't want it for her
but you do want it for other people's
kids
because you don't care about them that's
really what this comes down to
yes these these girls are degrading
themselves but you personally don't
care if they do you might be you might
even enjoy it when they do
because you don't know them and aren't
related to them and don't love them
that's your position if you're being
honest about it
your position is yes matt you're right
it's degrading
but i don't care
and for that reason you're canceled
though i would invite anyone if you are
a parent and you want to prove me wrong
and you want to come out publicly and
say no i want my daughter to be a
prostitute
you go ahead and do that you go ahead
and do that prove me wrong
but i don't think you will because again
i'm right
100 and you're 100 wrong and also
canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content